thanks to curiosity stream for keeping
legal eagle in the air
did somebody say lawyer Richard a
bottom-feeder a Tony at law I take
exception to that lawyers are not bottom
feeders even when they're literal bottom
feeding fish hate legal eagles it's time
to think like a lawyer and today we are
covering the highly requested episode of
Spongebob Squarepants Krabs vs. plankton
this will probably be the last cartoon I
cover for a while you can check out my
breakdowns of the Simpsons and South
Park down in the description below I
thought it would be fun to end with an
example of maritime law and SpongeBob
SquarePants technically qualifies be
sure to comment in the form of an
objection which either sustain or
overrule and stick around until the end
of the video where i give SpongeBob
SquarePants a grade for legal realism so
without further ado let's dig in to this
episode of Spongebob Squarepants Krabs
vs. plankton okay so plankton is going
to the Krusty Krab in order to steal the
recipe for the Krusty Burger we don't
know that's the Simpsons don't he's
going to steal the recipe for the krabby
patty okay that's it the krabby patty
which is probably some sort of trade
secret in the same way that Kentucky
Fried Chicken is a trade secret or
coca-cola is a trade secret but I'm
guessing plankton probably does this on
more than one occasion kind of like wily
coyote that was easy maybe today is the
day I'm gonna steal the krabby patty
formula all right a classic slip and
fall case there is an entire genre of
lawsuits devoted to exactly this kind of
thing that's kind of personal injury
because it's so easy to fake your
injuries like this so this is the kind
of thing that gives lawyers and lawsuits
a bad name attempt to steal me formula
so you tried and tried you haven't had
the smallest nibble of my delicious 40
and you never will I mean the guy has
already injured himself there's no
reason to be mean to him in Taunton when
he's on the ground not a good idea for a
restaurant owner to be that malicious
how do you sleep at night know when
you're a complete failure there really
should be a wet floor sign yeah if that
were me who slipped all right sue old
man Krabs for all he's got you know
that's a very good point there probably
should be a wet floor sign in the
vicinity when someone is mopping up the
floor although query how you can mop up
a floor and have standing water when
you're literally under water in the
first place putting that aside for the
moment I think these patrons are
absolutely right that there should be a
wet floor sign in the vicinity does that
include the krabby patty formula of
course we don't need to drag this little
incident in the car do we well if you
transfer the krabby patty formula to me
I'll forget your gross negligence
[Music]
yeah so this is actually based off of
the real-life case of Whelan versus Van
Natta where someone went to a shop
legally but then snuck around in a
private residence that was attached to
the shop the issue at hand is the
question of being an invitee versus a
trespasser an invitee is someone that is
there for regular business purposes and
a trespasser is someone who does not
have permission to be on the premises
and generally speaking a landowner must
act as a reasonable person would toward
invitees and to figure out what a
reasonable person would do you look
towards others who were in exactly the
same place given that we see wet floor
signs just about everywhere you can bet
a reasonable restaurant owner would
probably put one out if they were
mopping
fluor or they probably wouldn't leave
standing water in your restaurant in the
first place where people can trip and
fall now with respect to trespassers
though a restaurant owner or a land
owner doesn't owe the same duty of care
basically if someone is trespassing on
your property your only obligation is to
not hide dangerous things or create
dangerous situations on the premises
like a guy who created a shotgun booby
trap to punish people who were breaking
into his house haha you know what's
really interesting about this particular
case is that California did away with
that invites a trespasser distinction
and replaced it with a sort of general
reasonable person standard in the case
of Rollins versus Christian the invitee
trespasser distinction was found to be
unhelpful by the court and the court
just held that the landowner owes a duty
to act as a reasonable man now a
reasonable person in sort of general so
it doesn't really matter what the status
of the person who was injured on the
property is you just always have to act
as a reasonable person mr. krabs has not
put out the sign that says there's a wet
floor and so he's probably liable under
the California standard now of course
plankton is malingering here and he's
faking all of his injuries so that this
sort of shows you that he hasn't
actually suffered any damages here in
this particular case and he's really
perpetrating a fraud on both crabs and
the court but sometimes you can have a
court case where you're entitled to
$1.00 in damages because I think crabs
may have been in the wrong to not have a
sign out with respect to everybody else
and so plankton fell he just didn't
really have much damage as a result of
that so he might be entitled to what are
called nominal damages and a jury might
end up awarding him $1 instead of the
millions and the recipe that he's
actually seeking don't worry mr. Krabs I
will do whatever it takes to keep the
Krusty Krab formula from getting into
Plankton's evil hands
that I really need is a good lawyer oh
did somebody say lawyer Richard a
bottom-feeder attorney at law I take
exception to that lawyers are not bottom
feeders even when they're literal bottom
feeding fish
I couldn't help but notice that
despicable display so how much is this
gonna cost me actually I won't charge a
dime unless we win yeah that's a pretty
standard thing for a plaintiff's
attorney to charge and especially in a
personal injury lawsuit because of the
risk and and generally speaking if
you're a plaintiff in a personal injury
case you probably don't have the fees to
pay someone hundreds of dollars an hour
to represent you so a plaintiff's lawyer
in this particular situation would
probably ask for somewhere in the
neighborhood of thirty five to fifty
percent of any recovery well it sounds
like a lot the lawyer is actually in a
precarious position where number one the
lawyer might not recover anything and
number two the lawyer has to front a lot
of the court fees and court costs that
go along with lawsuit which can add up
pretty quickly in fact I think we should
count as sue for everything plankton old
[Music]
that so that is kind of a real thing you
are allowed to countersue generally what
people do is they file what are called
compulsory counterclaims so they are
things that arise from the same set of
facts and here crabs doesn't really have
any compulsory counterclaims there's
nothing that must be brought at the same
time that results from the same nexus of
facts that the lawsuit arises from the
opposite of that is a permissive
counterclaim which you can bring in the
same action or you can bring it whatever
you want because it doesn't really
relate to the claim at hand that's what
this lawyer is asking to bring in is
whatever past deeds have happened there
is some efficiency gain because you're
already hashing out this claim against
the same party but courts don't really
like permissive counterclaims because it
really multiplies the number of things
that they have to deal with what is it
lad I thought you might wanna hear my
testimony for when you call me as a
character witness I've been rehearsing
it actually spongebob we won't be
needing any testimony from you well
you'd be more of a
I'm a liability than an asset yeah and
also you wouldn't really have a
character witness in a slip-and-fall
case like this anyway the character
witness has no bearing on whether
negligence has occurred here whether
there was a duty whether it was a breach
of that duty it just there's no reason
you would complicate things and it's a
good idea not to call Sponge Bob
Squarepants to the stand
run along make things shipshape for my
victory celebration
I gotta get to the courthouse early
there's only a few free parking places
this is gonna be a slam dunk
[Music]
so sometimes this does actually happen
sometimes the lead trial counsel is
rendered incapacitated and you have to
pick up with somebody else
in fact when I interviewed my friend
Brent Wisner who was the lead trial
counsel in the Monsanto roundup cases
the original lead trial counsel who was
slated to handle everything was injured
in a windsurfing accident just weeks
before trial so he had to pick up on the
eve of trial and handle the whole thing
himself before he got a two billion
dollar verdict so it does happen from
time to time
I'll give you one last chance I'll drop
the charges the formula I will say this
is a little ridiculous it doesn't make
any sense that plankton would actually
fight crabs I don't think plankton
actually even have arms and I don't even
think crabs and plankton interact with
each other in the ocean anyway if only
there were a biologist that could rank
these animals in some sort of a tier
ocean glowing crabs and zooplankton
interact quite frequently in the reef
meta spongebob's plankton is most likely
based on the species of plankton called
the copy pod a microscopic animal that's
actually in the same subphylum as mr.
crabs
since they're both crustaceans similar
to how those battles are depicted in the
show one-on-one it's really no contest
crab builds that use the filter-feeding
ability to actually directly target
plankton mains as their main source of
XP so yeah as it turns out
SpongeBob's depiction of the one-sided
rivalry between mr. crabs and plankton
is actually fairly reasonable if you're
interested in what the tier lists for
the rest of the Bikini Bottom residence
looks like be sure to check out my
channel after you're done here huh well
that's good to know thanks tears ooh now
let's get back to the trial mr. Krabs
where is your attorney don't know where
he could be
thank you for joining us mr. spongebob
lawyer pants Your Honor yeah that is the
unauthorized practice of law you are not
allowed to represent other people if you
have not gone to law school and passed
the bar and spongebob would face serious
repercussions from pretending to be a
lawyer right now what are you doing here
spongebob your lawyer fell down on the
job but don't worry mr. Krabs
I have everything under control it's uh
all in here really yep right yeah that's
not gonna end well is there a problem
your lawyer didn't give me the
combination is the plaintiff ready to
proceed yes your honor although it's
very sympathetic I really would not
counsel plankton to represent himself
here he would do much better to have an
actual lawyer to represent him instead
of doing everything on his own that
doesn't tend to end well for people
always the tortured shell of a protozoa
that writhes in pain before you today
was a vibrant carefree happy-go-lucky
single cell
pull yourself together boy then came the
fateful day that I paid an inch
admission to the deathtrap known as the
krusty krab
not a bad opening statement so far I
kind of like it very persuasive and
definitely hits on some good emotional
beats upon recent establishment I found
myself without any warning slipping and
finally falling onto a hard unforgiving
floor with a viscous fluid you know he's
a little bit over the top here in this
opening statement it doesn't actually
matter if crabs intentionally put the
water there or not certainly if he did
intentionally put the water and tried to
hurt some people then that would be far
more than actual negligence and that
would border on an intentional tort but
just the fact that he was careless and
did not do what a normal restaurant
owner would do would be enough to be
guilty in this case liable for
negligence where was I oh yeah but the
worst part my dreams of completing a
marathon like I promised my old crabby
[Music]
[Music]
does the defense have an opening
statement
yes your honor I probably don't need to
tell you that that is a terrible opening
statement and they would have done
better to reserved their opening
statement and give it at this start of
their case-in-chief after the plaintiff
is already gone yeah so far spongebob
not doing a good job and by the way it
shows how important preparation is
before the trial itself they've done no
discovery whatsoever they just went
straight into trial and they haven't
even been able to open the briefcase
that contains their entire defense mr.
krabs can you identify this item it's a
wet floor sign do you own one well no I
don't I gotta hand it to plankton that's
a great question to ask on
cross-examination assuming that plankton
knows that Krabs does not in fact own
one of these signs that is probative to
the case at hand it helps demonstrate
his negligence that by the fact that he
doesn't own the sign he couldn't put it
out and the sign potentially would have
prevented his injury in this particular
case good cross-examination well done I
had to make some tough business
decisions in the sign seem superfluous
yeah I don't think that matters
no more questions your witness mr.
lawyer pants
yeah I don't know if plankton should
have stopped the cross-examination there
he could have gotten some other good
points but I also don't think crabs is
defense that he doesn't have the money
for the sign would hold any water here
if you're not financially able to have a
sign that is sort of necessary for all
restaurants and stores to have odds are
you probably shouldn't be in business so
I don't think that's a good defense to
the fact that he did not own and did not
put out this wet floor sign may it
please the court ladies and gentlemen of
the jury my client has been called cheap
lies early and chronically tight-fisted
hmm this is not relevant and not helpful
it's cheap as the prosecution claims he
is would he be able to sit there quietly
while I took out $1 and dropped it in
the London
[Music]
yeah so in addition to showing that
spongebob did no preparation in terms of
preparing his witness and defendant for
actually taking the stand here he's also
asking questions that are in no way
relevant to the case at hand whether or
not crabs as cheap in general does
nothing to address the fact of whether
he committed a negligent Act in the
first place except to the extent that
the plankton has already done to show
that that crabs didn't own a sign and
therefore he couldn't put it out which
definitely does go to negligence so
spongebob not doing a great job here
he's arguing against his own client does
the defense have any witness to call yes
your honor
defense calls split word to the stand Oh
Squidward a loyal employee mr. Squidward
is it my client has been called cheap
would you agree with that ludicrous
statement yes you know again this has no
relevance and the last thing you want to
do is try to show character here when
it's not relevant to the case at hand
can you tell the court of some instance
of mr. Krabs is generosity in any way
nope can I go now generosity not
relevant you who made the floor slippery
wasn't it the question need I remind you
the two sir are under oath I don't know
how you put him up under oath but yeah
he would be under oath it's it's just
his lunch or is it
defense calls plugged into the stands
why did you go into the krusty krab that
day ah that's a really good question
that would definitely help this case if
plankton actually answers truthfully
here to you know say hello to my once
good friend mr. Krabs what are you sure
it wasn't to make off with one of these
aha getting to the heart of the matter
gotcha weren't you there to steal the
formula of the most delicious
sweet-smelling sandwich known to Bikini
Bottom krabby patty
[Music]
well he didn't really answer the
question but he did show that he was
faking all of his injuries which
probably is not going to be good for his
particular case but interestingly as we
established putting aside the fact that
plankton totally faked all of his
injuries depends on the jurisdiction if
they were in California I think arguably
Krabs was probably in the wrong if we're
in most states however plankton was in
the wrong because he was a trespasser
not an invitee as the jury reached a
verdict we have your honor we find the
defendant not guilty
but he is cheap so this is a simple case
simple cases don't decide guilt or
innocence simple cases decide damages
and who's liable and who's not liable so
the jury would not decide that Krabs was
not guilty they would decide that he was
not liable and owed no damages I made
you a present close your eyes and hold
out your hand it's a web for sign I made
it myself so it's better than nothing I
guess
[Music]
okay so now it's time to give this
episode of Spongebob Squarepants a grade
for legal realism on the one hand you
have a really interesting fact pattern
that is clearly based on real-life cases
and deals with real issues like the
standard of care that is owed to people
that are on your property and whether
someone is an invitee versus a
trespasser on the other hand you have
some unauthorized practice of law you
have an abbreviated time period and you
have some ridiculous interspecies
fighting and fraud on the courts but
although I'm pleasantly surprised at how
much realism they were able to squeeze
into ten minutes so I'm gonna give this
episode of Spongebob Squarepants a C+
specifically a pineapple under the sea
I am now going to assault your mind with
subliminal messages now this is not the
first time that tears you and I have
teamed up in fact we actually helped
build a platform for creators so they
don't have to worry about things like D
monetization it's called nebula and
we're partnering with the curiosity
stream as you may know some friends and
I recently launched our own streaming
service called nebula featuring lots of
YouTube's top educational ish creators
including Polyphonic knowing better
Wendover Lindsay Alice 12-tone and of
course tears ooh we get the freedom to
create and we never have to worry about
the dreaded algorithm tears you and I
are actually competing to see who can
get more signups please don't make me
look bad in front of tears ooh
but seriously we put a lot of work into
this we are really proud of the result
it's a place where creators can do what
they do best
create it's a place where we can both
house content add free and also
experiment with new original series that
probably wouldn't work on YouTube
including an exclusive series called
working titles where every episode a
different creator breaks down their
favorite TV intro sequence polyphonic
did Game of Thrones Patrick Williams did
x-men and I'll be covering Law & Order
very soon so what does this have to do
with curiosity stream well they love
educational content and educational
creators so they are the perfect partner
for nebula we recently just worked out a
deal where if you sign up for curiosity
stream using the link in the description
not only will you get a one-month free
trial for curiosity stream but you'll
also get a nebula subscription for free
and to be clear that nebula subscription
is not a trial it's free for as long as
you are a curiosities to remember which
means that for less than 20 bucks a year
not only do you get unlimited access to
curiosity streams massive library of
gorgeous high budget documentaries
you'll also get to enjoy the private
playground for YouTube's best educators
for no additional charge and you'll be
supporting the creators like me directly
it's a win win win win win so if you
click on the link in the description not
only will you be able to access
curiosity streams amazing documentaries
like bright now which is a fantastic
deep
I've into timely stories about global
issues but you'll also get a
subscription to nebula the platform made
by creators for creators so click on the
link and check it out I promise you
won't be disappointed
so do you agree with my grade leave your
objections in the comments and check out
my other legal reactions over here where
I will see you in court